let's talk about abortion so I told you
right before we started so I am
pro-choice I've been pro-choice my
entire life I can treat people who are
pro-life respectfully and I've had many
of them on here and have had interesting
conversations I think I think that the
abortion one brings out something in the
national dialogue that sort of gets to
the heart of all of the anger where it's
like you know if you're on the right you
say that the left hates babies and if
you're on the Left you say that the
right hates women and I think that's
just an absolutely false choice but
that's really what we're being thrown at
all the time you are pro-choice but a
little bit yeah I mean I agree with you
that right now it's getting culturally
frayed 'add but I think that women
should have the ability to make their
own determination it's a deeply personal
decision I mean in an ideal society
whatever whenever a woman was getting
pregnant should be excited to like you
know like bring the baby in the world
but in like that's not the world we live
in and so I want to protect women's
reproductive rights in any way I can and
do you have a cut-off point is there a
set amount of weeks or months that at
that point well certainly I find late
term abortions to be like I you know
really problematic but my understanding
is that those are extraordinarily rare
unless there's some sort of medical
circumstance and so I would be reluctant
to have some sort of date cutoff because
again in my view it should be up to the
woman what to do yeah so six months a
woman has a perfectly viable fetus at
six months and you would still give her
that choice I would
[Music]